es gibt im Moment einige verdächtig
auffällige Operationen auch und gerade
an an frontsektoren über die wir jetzt
überhaupt nicht sprechen also in ganz im
Osten an der Front wo wo selbst Ziele in
der oblastung ganz beschossen werden mit
mit Heimat ist es möglich dass das
Ablenkungen sind es ist aber auch
möglich dass das tatsächlich zu der
Offensive dazu gehört
auch sehr richtig gesagt die vergangenen
ukrainischen offensiven waren keine
eigentlichen mechanisierten Initiativen
sondern sie zielten vor allem darauf die
russische Logistik abzuschneiden und mit
Artillerie den Russen klar zu machen
dass sie eingekesselt werden und
abgeschnitten von ihrer Versorgung wenn
sie sich nicht zurückziehen das war
eigentlich genau das Vorgehen in der
Operation zwischen
die wir im September 22 gesehen haben
das war das Vorgehen bei der
Rückeroberung von Fresse und das hat
fantastisch funktioniert einfach weil
die russischen Truppen einfach nicht
lernfähig sind in der Hinsicht also man
kann jetzt pragmatisch sagen sie machen
die gleichen Fehler immer wieder sie
haben einfach auch gewisse logistische
Beschränkungen einfach Sie müssen sich
zwingend auf Eisenbahnlinien verlassen
wenn Sie die nicht zur Verfügung haben
müssen sie lange umständliche substitute
organisieren mit mit LKWs und
improvisierten munitionslagern die kann
man sehr leicht sehen und angreifen also
sprich die Ukraine hat in logistischer
Hinsicht einfach den Vorteil dass sie
die Russen da sehr empfindlich treffen
kann und ich sag das immer wieder man
muss über die ukrainische Offensive eben
nicht denken als mechanisierte Operation
sondern das Ziel ist dass die russische
Position unhaltbar wird und haltbar im
logistischen Sinne also spricht dass die
Truppen nicht mehr versorgt werden
können aber dass die Ukraine sie aus der
Ferne angreifen und abschließen können
das gilt für die Südfront über die wir
jetzt sprechen genauso wie dann auch
später für die Krim also sprich es ist
nicht notwendig mechanisiert auf die
Krim vor zurück Rücken wie das zum
Beispiel mahnstein gemacht hat 1941 im
Zweiten Weltkrieg sondern es reicht eben
glaubwürdig damit zu tun dass die
gesamte Logistik auf der Creme
abgeriegelt wird und die russische
Position damit unhaltbar wird es sei
denn sie ziehen sich zurück
lassen sie uns vielleicht noch mal einen
Blick auf die Karte werfen die
uns das mal zeigt wir haben sie vorhin
schon gesehen wo eben diese
Schutzwälle und Gräben sind sie sagen
gerade es ist überhaupt nicht notwendig
da überall durchzukommen um wieder über
vielleicht auch die Krim zu sprechen
können Sie uns das hier einmal zeigen
was sie genau damit meint
vielleicht wenn Sie noch etwas stärker
auf den Nordteil der Krim hinein zoomen
dann dann sehen wir genau
da sehen wir jetzt so links oben sehen
wir die den Ismus von perikopf also die
Landenge über die die meisten
mechanisierten Invasionen der Krim
stattgefunden haben und ähm rechts da
sehen wir so eine ganz dünne kleine
Linie das ist die Landenge von arabert
auch da gab es im 19 und 20 Jahrhundert
Operation aber sie sehen es ist sehr
schwierig die Krim mechanisiert
einzunehmen also als Mannstein damals
1941 gemacht hat da das war eine sehr
blutige sehr verlustreiche Operation die
ging auch über den Ismus von perekopp
und sie sehen genau dort finden Sie auch
die große Konzentration an diesen Gräben
und Verteidigungsanlagen also sie sehen
klar die Erwartungshaltung wenn es eine
Invasion der Krim gibt dann wird die
wieder so ablaufen wie im Zweiten
Weltkrieg und
man muss das eben anders denken man muss
denken dass das Ziel der Ukraine wird
eher sein an die Schwarzmeerküste
vorzustoßen also irgendwo an die Küste
zwischen der janz und ähm und dem Beginn
hier dieser dieser arabert Landgänge
oder sie sehen was für ein riesiger Raum
das ist ja aber sobald sie da sind und
Raketen Artillerie dort aufstellen
können also sagen wir mit einer
Reichweite zwischen 80 und 170 km dieses
System hat die Ukraine dann können Sie
im Prinzip jedes Ziel auf der Krim
treffen das heißt dass sie können die
Creme sozusagen aus der Ferne Regeln und
damit die Position der Russen unhaltbar
machen weil sie einfach jedes Ziel dann
erreichen können und damit glaubwürdig
drohen können nicht nur die russische
Logistik abzuschneiden die befindet sich
nämlich ironischerweise ganz im Norden
der Krim in junkoyim das ist der
zentrale Eisenbahnknotenpunkt und wo
auch die Munitionslager sind auch eine
wichtige Airbase und wenn sie sehen das
hier diese diese große Konzentration
hier von Gräben gerade nördlich von John
Cole
und wenn Sie wenn Sie diese Logistik
hier rausnehmen dann können Sie sich
ganz leicht vorstellen da kommt nichts
mehr auf die Krimi hinein und nichts
mehr aus der krimin hinaus dann haben
sie nämlich nur noch ein Zugangsweg
nämlich die Brücke von catch und ich
vermute mal das wird auch der
Rückzugsweg sein den man den Russen
offen halten wird also das ist ein
Szenario wie der Krieg enden könnte man
ähm also wenn man dieses operative Ziel
erreicht dann sagt man den Russen schaut
ähm ihr seid jetzt eingekapsel auf der
Krim entweder zieht ihr euch zurück wir
lassen die Brücke von kaufen oder ihr
werdet einfach vernichtet ist ein
mögliches Szenario ist sicher eines der
optimistischeren aber ich denke dass das
unmittelbare Ziel dass wir dass wir uns
klarmachen müssen ist die Russen müssen
prognostizieren wo genau die Ukraine
durchbrechen und landen wird nochmal die
gesamte Frontlinie ist 1200 km lang und
die Abschnitte über die wir hier
sprechen da sprechen wir über über
küstenlängen von 100 bis 300 km und die
Russen müssen jetzt den Punkt ausmachen
an der Frontlinie wo geschieht der
Durchbruch und wo ist der Endpunkt und
sie können sich vorstellen weil bei
diesen riesigen räumen wir müssen uns
immer klar machen die Ukraine ist größer
als Frankreich und diese orange
markierten Gebiete die sind ungefähr so
groß wie die Schweiz und Österreich
zusammen
es gibt in der Idee von der Größe der
Räume über die wir hier reden und die
Russen müssen jetzt einen Punkt
prognostizieren waren also einen einen
kleinen Durchmesser von vielleicht drei
bis fünf Kilometern wo dann der
mechanisierte Durchstoß erfolgen wird
wie machen sie sowas oder also die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie falsch
liegen ist natürlich sehr viel höher als
die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie richtig
liegen auch die Möglichkeit dann spontan
noch irgendwie um zu disponieren wenn du
Durchbruch woanders stattfindet dass Sie
gedacht haben die sind natürlich auch
beschränkt das heißt also das ist genau
was ihr Korrespondent gerade gesagt hat
die Ukraine ähm fördert natürlich auch
diese Diskussion und Spekulationen ganz
bewusst auch in ihrer eigenen Propaganda
einfach um zu sagen ja es kann im
Prinzip überall sein ist gehört dieser
Beschuss jetzt da im Osten wirklich zu
der Initiative oder ist das ein
Ablenkung kommt sie jetzt kommt sie erst
im Mai es ist wirklich eine Kakophonie
von von ganz unterschiedlichen auch
widersprüchlichen Äußerungen und ich
denke nicht dass das Zufall ist